and NATO defense ministers have met to
address key issues for our security
this includes stepping up our support
for Ukraine
strengthening our returns and defense
with the right forces capabilities and
stockpiles
and protecting our critical
infrastructure by strengthening our
military planning and our cooperation
with the industry
it's almost one year since Russia
launched its full-fledged invasion of
Ukraine the biggest conflict in Europe
since World War II
and we see no signs that Russia is
preparing for peace on the contrary
offensives
yesterday defense means wrestling curve
update the NATO ministers on the
situation and Ukraine's most urgent
needs
a welcome the new pledges of support
made by NATO allies including more heavy
weapons and military training
this is critical
Ukraine has a window of opportunity to
tip the balance
and time is of the essence
I want to thank allies for the
significant contributions including the
NATO's comprehensive assistance package
this is providing Ukraine with food fuel
medical supplies counter drone systems
and and amphibious Bridges
ministers also discussed our commitment
to our to our other partners at risk
including Bosnia and Herzegovina
Georgia animal
and we agreed to step up tailored
support to enhance their defense
capabilities resilience and
interoperability with NATO
today our allies took steps to further
strengthen NATO's deterrence and events
since our historic Madrid Summit we have
been making good progress
boosting our forward defenses and
upgrading our redness and defense plans
allies agree new guidance for NATO's
defense planning
this reflects the reality that we live
in a more dangerous world
we just sells aggressive behavior
the persistent threat to terrorism and
the challenges posed by China
NATO's defense planning will drive
capability changes for the years to come
and ensure that our deterrence and
defense remain strong and credible
ministers also addressed ways to abuse
industrial capacity and replenish
stockpiles apartments and munitions
NATO allies are providing unprecedented
support to help Ukraine push back
against Russia's aggression at the same
time this is consuming an enormous
quantity of Allied ammunition and
depleting our stockpiles
allies agree on the need to work hand in
hand with the defense industry to ramp
up our industrial industrial capacity
we already
and we are reviewing NATO capability
targets for ammunition stockpiles
and are welcome the important
multinational projects agreed by allies
today
these include a project on uh on
ammunition warehousing which will
support a pre-positioning and
stockpiling Allied ammunition as well as
a project on ground-based air defense
today ministers also addressed the
security of all undersea infrastructure
the sabotage of the north stream
pipelines has reminded us all of the
vulnerabilities we face
ministers Thomas the NATO military
authorities to provide advice a lot more
we should do including two better
coordination and cooperation with the
private sector
and I am standing up a critical undersea
infrastructure coordination cell here at
the NATO headquarters
led by Lieutenant General Hans Vernal
Biermann a highly respected former
military officer
I will it will facilitate engagement
with industry and bring key military and
civilian stakeholders together
to share best practices
leverage Innovative Technologies and
boost the security or undersea
infrastructure
at our Summit in millions leaders who
take further decisions to ensure that
NATO can effectively coordinate between
military civilian and private server to
secure our critical undersea
infrastructure
as we continue to adapt our alliance
we need to have the right resources
so ministers also discuss the importance
of investing in defense
more countries are now spending at least
two percent of the GDP on defense
and 2022 was the eighth consecutive year
of increased defense spending by
Europeans and Canada
with an additional investment of 350
billion dollars
this trend is expected to continue this
year but more needs to be done
so today Alice discussed how to build on
the defense investment pledge
and on future commitments beyond the
2024.
NATO leaders will take decisions on this
at our next Summit in Vilnius with that
I'm ready to take your questions
General Jonathan Beale BBC News um
started this meeting and and the head of
the contact group saying that
you're making the point that Ukraine is
using and Russia you're using huge
amounts of ammunition you repeated that
just now and you warned about
NATO's own stockpiles of ammunition the
production needed to be wrapped up
first of all the countries
actually now committed to ramp up their
production apart from the U.S and France
which you mentioned earlier signing a
new contract
and the second question is is you know
we get a message from Lord Austin the
U.S defense secretary that Ukraine is
getting what it needs but what you're
suggesting is that Ukraine might not get
what it needs that it will run out of
artillery shells tank shells for example
so are you worried that Ukraine
could run out of ammunition in the
coming months thank you so what we see
is an enormous expenditure of ammunition
and we have seen that for several months
and that's also the reason why we
actually started to address that last
fall uh we we couldn't wind with uh
meetings with the defense industry we
addressed this issue in different NATO
capitals and now we see that things are
actually moving in the right direction
um yes the United States France have
signed the contracts but also other
allies Germany Norway and there are also
others who have already signed contracts
with the defense industry meaning that
production is not ramping up and and
that is making a huge difference and
partly it's possible to increase uh
production from the existing uh uh uh so
factories uh capabilities but of course
uh you also need to make new Investments
that will take some more time uh but
actually while happening utilizing
existing capacity more and investing in
new production uh capacity
um so the production of for instance
um artillery shells the 11155 is now uh
increasing and that enables us to uh
both replenish our own stocks which we
have depleted but also to continue to
provide support to to Ukraine
um and we also do this by
working together allies are jointly
addressing the need to also joint
procurement uh to to make big orders
from the industry to utilize the economy
of scale and and to place bigger orders
and to give the defense industry the
long-term uh demand and the and the
long-term uh contracts so yes things are
happening but we need to continue we
need to uh step uh up even more because
there is a big need out there and to
provide Ukraine with ammunition this is
now becoming a a grinding war or
attrition and a war attrition is a war
of logistics and uh and uh and therefore
this is so crucial for our ability to
ensure that Ukraine wins is able to
retake territory and launch offensives
that ensures that
it's able to to to win the war and to
Prevail as a serving independent nation
we have seen the the big need and that's
why we have uh reacted several months
ago and now we see that contracts are
signed and production is ramping up and
an allies are producing more to be able
to continue to support Ukraine
a TT news agency from Sweden
Victor number in Swedish news agency TT
following your doorstep yesterday
there's been a lot of speculation if
there's a new line on the membership
process for Finland and Sweden so just
to clarify if there would be a
ratification for one of the countries
would NATO go through and complete the
complete process for membership or would
you still wait in order to get
everything clear with both countries at
the same time
and Sweden they applied together and all
NATO allies made an historic decision to
gather all 30 to invite Finland and
Sweden
Summit in Madrid and then
all allies all 30 allies also treaty
signed the two accession protocols
together
and our military actually last fall when
I went to Turkey in in October that that
both Finland and Sweden has now
fulfilled their obligations
in the joint trilateral memorandum
designed with turkey in in July so I I
urged turkey to to ratify both Finland
and Sweden together all the last fall so
that's my position that position also
has not changed
but at the same time
we have also seen that there are
different Assessments in Turkey about to
uh to what extent Finland and Sweden or
to say are in the same position to be
ratified
and that is a Turkish decision
turkey has turkey has two documents one
accession protocol with Finland and one
accession protocol with Sweden
so the decisions we need to take as
Vietnam Finland and 30 allies signed the
accession protocols now it's for the
individual allies to ratify 28 allies
have already ratified both protocols
um and then Hungary and turkey has not
and therefore it is for turkey to decide
weather day ratified both and I have
recommended that
or whether they ratify only one of the
two documents that's not a NATO decision
it's a decision by to
so again my position is that both
Finland and Sweden are ready for
membership both accession protocols
should be ratified by all allies but at
the end of the day it is a decision by
turkey whether they ratify one or both
of them
but then but then
it's completed
there's no need for any unanimous
decision anymore by NATO we have made
the decision we have invited both at the
same time
so so so so when turkey and ratifies
then the process is completed
as long as also of course Hungary and
also Finland Sweden do what they are
also now in the process of uh of doing
so so this idea that there is a need for
a new and an unanimous decision by NATO
is wrong
there are decisions that has to be taken
by by the individual allies and two
allies are not yet ratified and of
course again I I have urged them for
many months to read both at the same
time
and that's still my position has never
changed I've been actually pushing hard
for Swedish and unfinished membership
and uh and I am absolutely confident
that both Finland and Sweden will become
a member uh at the same time the
sequencing is not the most important
thing the most important thing is that
both Finland and Sweden uh soon uh
become members of The Alliance and I
I'll push hard for that I also actually
travel to
address
could you please uh give us the latest
information about the relief efforts
NATO's relief efforts for the victims of
the earthquakes in Turkey
all allies expressed their deepest
control condolences and support to uh
turkey our Ally and the deepest
condolences for the loss of lives in
turkey and uh and Syria caused by the
terrible uh earthquake last week and uh
NATO allies partners are NATO has have
stepped up their support and are
providing different types of relief
support and NATO has also decided to
deploy
shelters to accommodate people who have
been displaced and and we will the plan
is transport is within a few days to to
Kia
tomorrow I will be in here to meet with
president erdogan and Minister and
express my solidarity my condolences and
to continue to address with them how
NATO and NATO allies and can provide
relief support and help alleviate the
the suffering and and and the
consequences of the terrible earthquake
uh so um so I I I thank allies for the
support I did actually I ended the
meeting today to call on allies to
provide even more support to his urgent
need for more strategic airlift and NATO
allies have provided strategically left
within more airlift to actually bring in
tents uh and uh and and relief to uh to
uh to Ukraine and we started also the
meeting yesterday with uh with a moment
of silence in in Solarity with the
victims of the earthquake
okay we'll go to keep post
thank you Anna Secretary General uh Alex
bobronikov Keith post Ukraine I firstly
there's a there's an ongoing a talk eye
of the open doors policies of NATO while
Ukraine being a sphere had a spear force
of the anti-totalitarian war happening
right now I we still are in a situation
with this there's no news on potential
membership to Ukraine I do you feel like
during your stay as a Secretary General
this historical shift may happen uh
through the membership action plan or
any other facility I this old-fashioned
ways of uh NATO's uh developing its
potential in future Partners that's one
thing one question and the second one
would be on due diligence of allied help
to Ukraine uh Mr reznikov has flagged
yesterday that this is an ongoing talk
on uh basically so to say do digital
diligence or checking the uh the
situation there with the how the the
assets were used where do we stand on
that and what's what we what we can
expect thank you so first of all on
membership what I have demonstrated and
not need to analyze have demonstrated
over the last years is that NATO's door
is open uh we have uh two new members
Montenegro and North Macedonia both time
Russia protested heavily but the allies
and and these individual countries
decided uh their own path and uh and uh
and and we invited them and they're now
members then uh Finland Sweden are very
close to membership
they are now
invited to the alliance they participate
in NATO structures meetings they're at
the NATO table they are more and more
integrated into NATO's civilian and
Military structures including in defense
so so so we are very close to also have
two more Finance in us as full-fledged
members on Ukraine NATO's position has
not changed
we have retreated many times at the
Ukraine will become a member of the
alliance but the focus now is to ensure
that Ukraine wins the war because the
only way to to to to integrate and to
and and to ensure that that that Ukraine
can move towards uh
cooperation because of your Atlantic
operation is to ensure that Ukraine
prevails as a sovereign independent
nation so the Urgent the the main focus
of NATO allies is to ensure that Ukraine
gets the weapons the supplies the
ammunition they need uh to push back the
Russian uh in Invaders
um and we're also work on more long-term
uh partnership uh helping Ukraine to
to to to to to to move from the
soviet-era weapons doctrines uh uh
search to Nato standards to improve
interoperability on security and defense
reform and all of that will move Ukraine
uh closer to the NATO alliance
um uh then of course the best proof that
that the support works and it's actually
helping Ukraine it is the progress
Ukraine has uh delivered on the
battlefield
um and our allies are also of course
constantly working with the Ukrainian
authorities to ensure that all the money
all the funding ends up where it should
okay but that's also we have very close
contact with them all the time to ensure
that that we have the necessary
oversight and transparency
a Bloomberg
I mean that's the way we are ensuring
that that's happening
intelligence from Bloomberg
I wanted to scan defense spending you
said before that allies are increasingly
seeing two percent of GDP as a floor and
not a ceiling and after the discussions
today do you have any sense of whether
that two percent figure could increase
uh when When leaders agreed to the new
pledge this summer
so what what we had now was the initial
discussion among allies only the new
defense investment pledge because in
2014 NATO allies made the pledge to move
towards spending two percent of GDP on
defense by 2024. so when we meet this
this summer in July in Venus we need to
make a new pledge
um and that's obvious because the
current one is actually running out
um this what we had today was the
initial discussion and of course we
didn't conclude the conclusions are
going to be drawn at the summit they're
wrong but what is obvious is that if it
was right to commit to spend two percent
in 2014 it is even more right now
because we live in the more dangerous
World there is a full-fledged war going
on uh in uh in Ukraine in in Europe and
then we see the persistent threat of
terrorism and we see also the the
challenges that China is posing to our
security so it is obvious that we need
to spend more
um and my uh what should I say
thinking around this is that instead of
changing the two percent I think we
should move from uh regarding the two
processor ceiling to regard the two
percent of GDP as a floor a minimum and
to have a stronger commitment and not
the long-term perspective or move
towards but actually that we need
immediate
commitment to spend to present as a
minimum because we when we see the needs
for ammunition for air defense for
tradeliness for high-end capabilities
it's obvious that that